You
have questions.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank
again. Your third quiz is a week from
today, right? I know it got packed in
with the second quiz, but that's because
the break was so late this year by time
you came back. You know, I wouldn't want
to give it in the week you came back
because obviously wouldn't quite have
been ready. So your third quiz is a week
from today, 3:30 to 4. Same rules apply.
Open book, open notes. It'll cover
packet
two. It's pricing and today we're going
to talk about assetbased valuation.
Wednesday we're going to talk about
private company valuation. So it'll
pretty much cover packet
two. Today we're going to talk about
assetbased valuation. I thought I'd
start today's class by kind of putting
context. an assetbased valuation rather
than value a company you value it in
pieces know what I mean by pieces you're
a multi- regional company I can value
each region separately if you're a
multi- business company I can value each
business separately so my first question
is very simple question about why do we
do that right so you can value a company
let's say it's a multi- business Disney
you can value it as a company and you
can value the theme park business
separately the the
broadcasting which approach approach
will be uh more precise. You think
valuing it in pieces or evaluating it as
a as a company? What's the benefit of
valuing a company in pieces? You want to
try? Yeah.
You can look at that like and that's
followup. So basically the first is
precision and remember how you you know
most do you get the email about your
DCFS? If you still haven't got your DCF
back, I don't know where it is. So, send
it again because I've had 2,000 emails
in the last 10 days. And if you didn't
put the right subject in there, God only
knows where it's been buried. So, if you
didn't get it back, nothing personal.
Send it. But in your DCF, what did I
make you do? Tell a story about the
company, right? If you value it as
multiple businesses, what do you have to
do? You have to tell that. So, think of
it as five separate FC. If you're in
five businesses, five separate FCF,
you're saying that's a pain in the neck.
But the plus is you can give different
stories for different parts of the same
company. So it is more precise. So
you're saying why don't we do it every
single time. Which one requires more
information? The pieces approach because
now I need all of the numbers for each
piece, not just about revenues, but
margins and capex and working capital.
That's a tradeoff. Most of the time the
trade-off will lead you to just value
the company. But we will talk about
today why in some cases you might choose
to value a company in
pieces. So let's say you value it in
pieces. You add up the pieces. You
should come up with the value for the
company, right? Will that value be equal
to the value of the company you get by
valuing the entire company as an
aggregated whole? Greater than, less
than, or could any of those apply?
Under what conditions will the two be
the same? You think? Yeah.
Just question of synergies. For example,
Disney like but but remember synergies
can be valued in the sum of the parts as
well, right? So as long as I can
separate and put it somewhere, it should
show up.
It'll be less than the value of the most
companies you should expect it to be
less. You know why? Otherwise it'd be
broken up into pieces, right?
Otherwise, it know for the most part
though it should be less because
otherwise you'll have this unstable
equilibrium where people will be trying
to break each other up. But it could be
lower, it could be higher or it could be
the same. Most of the time you'd expect
the company to be worth more.
Today we'll talk about it. There'll be
three places where we use some of the
parts. One will be in liquidation. The
second is in fair value accounting.
Right? because you've got to identify
individual pieces. And the third is an
activist investor who wants to buy the
company and break it up and sell it off
into pieces. Okay? So, we're going to
get to act to assetbased valuation, but
there's still a little bit of pricing
left that I want to mop up on. So, let's
go there. And I want to start by
targeting those of you valuing money
losing companies, young companies,
right? Unity software young company
money losing
company so far every multiple we use
kind of works right in the sector use
price to book return equity works price
earnings growth but when you take a
company like unity software young
company and you try pricing the company
you're going to start to pull your hair
out so I'm going to take you back to
2000 none of you were born then I think
was anybody born in
2000 okay one person right but remember
that valuation of Amazon. I showed you
the intrinsic
valuation where I found the company to
be significantly overvalued. I think the
stock was trading at 84 and I came up
with the $35 value. At exactly the same
time, I decided to price Amazon relative
to other.com stocks. So, this is a graph
of price to sales ratios. And already
you should be picking on me.
Why I should have used EV to sales? I
was too I didn't know any better in
2000. I was sloppy. I was using price to
sales. But if I use price to sales,
what's the measure of profitability I
should look at? What margin? At least I
was being consistent. I was using net
margin. So this is a scatter plot of
price to sales ratios and net margins.
Everybody comfortable with what a what a
scatter plot does? You take each
company, you take the combination of
price to sales and margin. So each of
these is a dot company. When you look at
that graph and I ask you to fit a line
through it, what's your
reaction? It's a shotgun blast, right?
You would probably you could produce a
straight line, a upward sloping.
Undaunted, I decide to run a regression
anyway. I'm going to show you the
regression on the next page. What kind
of R square do you think I'm going to
get? That's
I beat you by It's 4%. I beat the 1% by,
you know, so it's but but there's an
even scarier piece of output in this
regression. Price to sales is 81.36
minus
7.554 times the net margin. How would I
read that? What is it telling
me? The more negative your margin, I'm
going to reverse it in a optimistic
spin. The more negative your margin, the
high. If I were writing a book on
irrational exuberance, this could be
exhibit one, right? Look how crazy
people are. But I think that's
dangerous. And here's why. People don't
pay for young high growth companies
based on how much money they made last
year. Let's play it out, right? Let's
assume people, even if they're
irrational, have a collective sense of
why they're doing what they're doing.
They're not paying based on last year's
profits. what are they using to
determine how much to pay or in the way
in the future right it's not even might
not even be next year and in revenue
growth so maybe they're not even looking
at profits they're saying how much will
revenues grow so that's second is that
multiple of revenues you're willing to
pay should be should become lower as the
revenues themselves become higher you
see why you have a million dollars in
revenues paying 100 times revenues not a
big deal 100 million you can do it based
on growth You have a billion dollars in
revenues. A 100 times revenues is now a
h 100red billion. So I'd expect the
price to sales ratio to decrease as
revenues climb. And there's one final
thing that as an investor I might think
about. What happens to most young money
losing
companies? They fail, right? So I'd like
something to proxy for chances of
survival. And let's think that through.
Why do most young companies fail? It's
not because they can't make a debt
payment. And it's just because they run
out of cash. What if I could tell you
how much cash each of these companies
has on its balance sheet? The more cash
you have, the greater I know it's a very
very simplistic measure of of survival.
In the late '9s, equity research analyst
followed.com companies would track how
many months of cash you had in your
balance sheet. The more months of cash
you had, the better you were as a
company because you could survive. So I
ran a regression based on those three
variables. See what I'm trying to do is
put myself in the shoes of somebody
buying a dot stock saying why would I
pay a high price high revenue growth and
I'm going to scale it to revenues. So
there's my price to sales ratio log of
revenues you're going to see me use
natural log anytime you have an
independent variable that is a very
large variation between the lowest and
the highest number. All logger the
natural log does is it makes the
difference smaller. It makes your
regression better behaved. I know a
statistics professor would kill me for
using a bludgeoner, but most of the time
a natural log works at reducing the
problems in your regression. So what am
I trying to capture there? The higher
the revenues, the lower the price to
sales ratio should be. Good news is the
sign is in the right. It's it's it's the
right sign, but the t statistic is not
significant. Now, if I were running this
regression, I wanted it to be I'd
probably take that out, but I'm going to
leave it in for the moment, right?
Higher revenue growth translates into
higher price to sales. Make sense? Yeah.
And more cash companies have, the higher
the price to sales, greater chance of
survival. The R squar is only 32%, but
in this sector, explaining 32% of what's
going on is a win. I'll take
it. I plugged in the numbers for Amazon
into this regression. Amazon's revenues,
Amazon's growth rate, which was 199% in
the previous year, and Amazon's cash,
which was 31% of revenues. And I got a
predicted price to sales for Amazon of
30.42. It was actually trading at 25.4
times
revenue. So, I'm going to say something
that's going to directly contradict what
I said a couple of minutes ago. A couple
of minutes ago I said an intrinsic value
basis Amazon is significantly
overvalued. At exactly the same time I'm
going to say on a pricing basis Amazon
is
underpriced. How would I reconcile those
two
opposite? You want to try what? How
would I reconcile the
two? Because some of you are going to
face this issue on your intrinsic
valuation. Your stock will be overvalued
and you're pricing it could be
underpriced. How do you reconcile the
two?
It would be helpful to have more like
CHDC. Let's step back. What what is the
question we're trying to answer in
intrinsic value? Well, whether the
present cash flows given the business,
the cash flows, the growth and the risk
is this company cheap or expensive?
Right? When I'm doing a pricing in this
pricing, what's the question I'm
answering? Given how other.com stocks
are being priced, how much would I pay
for Amazon?
What it is, but based upon how investors
treat other businesses in the same in
the dotcom sector, right? I would wage
the same thing is true for the AI space
right now, right? So a stock that trades
at 40 times revenues might look cheap
relative to other AI stocks now but
you're answering a you're saying which
one should I base my recommenda my buy
or sell recommendation on that's a
choice I leave to you and what's that
going to be driven
by whether you base it on your intrinsic
valuation your
pricing you got to make to make money
what has to happen the market has to
correct its mistakes right if you have a
six-month time horizon. Where are the
odds better for you? The pricing or the
valuation? The pricing, right? So, I
can't make that judgment for you because
I don't know what your time horizon is.
And that's why I leave the final
recommendation up to you is once you've
done the valuation, the pricing, you
will have to face that choice. So,
that's the first thing you can do with
young companies is put yourself in the
shoes of somebody looking. Is anybody
valuing a young biotech or a pharma
company? Because you have the same issue
there. You have to think about what do
investors price these companies based
on? You know what they usually price
them on? The total market for the drug
that they're developing. There's no
revenues, no earnings, no cash flows.
Right now, you have to base it in what
investors are looking
at. There's a second way you can deal
with young companies. Problem with young
companies is not there's not much of
substance on the ground right now. You
know what I mean by that? The revenues
are small, the earnings are negative.
But if you look at your own DCF, do the
numbers look much better in year five
and year 10? Right? Take Unity Software.
Revenues are what, five times higher
than they are today? Maybe they're
making profits. Do you see the second
pathway? Instead of basing what I paid
today based on what the earnings are
today, why can't I base it on expected
earnings in year 10? It's called a
forward multiple. So rather than pricing
the company today, you price it based on
year 10 revenues or year 10 earnings
where the numbers are more substantial.
You have to do analyst estimates and
earnings. But you're in the pricing
game. Remember this is not intrinsic
valuation anymore. You can cut corners.
You can be sloppy because everybody else
is. That's a great thing about pricing
is if everybody's sloppy, you can afford
to be sloppy as well. No.
the analyst numbers and say, "Well, hey,
I think expected for whatever is going
to be this number instead of what
analyst forecast." You could do that,
but then do it for all the companies.
See, that's the problem. You can't just
do it for your company and leave the
other companies and analyst forecast. If
you open that door, you got to walk all
the way in because you got to be
consistent.
Yeah, you do. That's a forward. If you
use a multiple, that's exactly what it
becomes, right? That's the only
difference between what we're doing here
and in in a discounted cash flow
valuation with the only way to estimate
terminal values to assume a growth rate
in perpetuity. And I talked about how
you could not use a pricing a multiple
to get the terminal value. If you do do
that, then it becomes a forward pricing.
And that's effectively what I want to
talk about next. A lot of analysts use
that forward multiple because you're
more of substance. You get a value 10
years from now, but you can't compare
that value 10 years from now to the
market cap today. Right? Think of why.
Let's start with time value. Pure time
value. This is from 10 years ago when I
valued Tesla. And I came up with a $69
billion terminal value which was twice
the market cap at that point in time. I
actually concluded Tesla was overvalued.
And people said, "How can it be
overvalued? They have this big terminal
value that's higher than the market cap
today." I said, "First, I'm not
factoring in pure time value of money.
just discount back at the risk-free
rate. My 68 billion becomes 52 billion.
So think of that as just a risk-free
rate and it's not a risk-free cash flow.
If I discounted a risk adjusted cost of
capital, the present value becomes 28
billion. Already you can see that
forward value becomes half of what it
was once you and I'm not quite done.
Remember for young growth companies what
the cash flows look like in year 1, year
2, year three. What is it? What do they
look like? Negative. Right? So there's
another drain in cash flows. That's a
delilution effect here. I've got to
factor it in. That lowers the value even
further. And there's one final
consideration. I have to get to year 10
to see this nirvana, right? There's a
failure risk that's going to reduce the
value. So the point I was trying to make
is that 69 billion in the terminal value
looks like this huge number. But then
when you start adjusting for all of
these effects, the value that I ended up
with for the equity was $8 billion.
Remember that proposition, the don't
freak out proposition where I said if
you have negative cash flows up front,
it's okay as long as you get a
disproportionately large positive cash
flow in the future. You can see it play
out here. So if you see analysts use
forward multiples, check to see if
they're being careful. Are they
factoring in time value? Are they
factoring in this negative cash flow
dilution effect? Are they factoring in
failure risk? And I can almost guarantee
you that they don't do it. Which means
they tend to overvalue companies using
forward multiples because they're not
factoring in all those drains. Yes. Hon.
Exactly. Right. Which means you're going
to go through all the work you did in
discounted cash or even if you don't use
the number the forward multiple value
has to be multiples of the market cap
today for it to be undervalued. Right?
So even if you don't go through any of
the mechanics, you can see it's going to
drop by 60 70 80 90% by the time you get
to the market cap. So if nothing else,
you can caution people saying it looks
great on a forward multiple basis, but I
haven't made any of the adjustments to
get to where I am
today. So in pricing, the market sets
the rules. You're data driven. This is
not about finance anymore. And that's
why I said there's no right way to
estimate risk. It's whatever the market
factors into the pricing. So I'll give
you an example. In October of 2013, a
company called Twitter went public. At
the time of its IPO, I valued Twitter
using an intrinsic valuation model. Came
up at $18 per share there. I also wanted
to price Twitter at the time. What
business is Twitter in? Please don't say
social media.
What is online advertising? So, you know
what? I went and collected publicly
traded companies that got the bulk of
their revenues from online advertising.
So, those are the companies and you can
see the market
caps. I also got the enterprise value
for each company. And then I wanted to
see what makes markets attach a higher
value to some companies and lower one.
And it's a purely empirical question.
And so I went out and collected
revenues, Ebidon, net income, hoping
that they would explain the difference.
And I also collected the number of users
on each platform. File that away. It's
not an accounting number, but I was able
to get that. How do you decide what
drives pricing? So I've given you the
market cap of these companies. I've
given you a bunch of accounting numbers.
How do you know which one's driving
differences in
pricing? Remember I said it was a
statistical question. So if I want to
see what drives pricing, all I have to
look at is the correlation between each
of the variables in the market cap.
Right? Again, as I said, it's not a
theory question, it's an empirical
question. And guess which variable best
explains differences in market cap? It's
number of users.
Not only does it explain 98% of the
variation in market cap, a median user
is valued at about
$100 per user. I know this is extremely
simplistic, but pricing is simplistic.
If the number of users best explains
differences in pricing across companies,
and a user is worth about
$100, here's how I'm going to price
Twitter. Twitter had 240 million users
at the time of its
IPO. Market pays $100 per user. So
what's Fred's pricing? 240 * 100 which
is 24 billion which coincidentally
happened to be the price at which it
went public on that first day. That's
what the stock price rose to. Pricing
better explains what you will see around
IPOs than any kind of intrinsic
valuation model because IPOs are a
pricing game. It's demand and supply and
you're gauging
that. Now, of
course, not all users are created equal,
right? A Facebook user is worth a lot
more than a Twitter user from an
advertising perspective. Why is
that, Ryan? To make money in
advertising, what does a user have to be
doing? Be on your site looking at your
site. Right? This wasn't available in
2013, but by 2015, people were tracking
how many minutes people were on each
site. Facebook is a typical Facebook
user was spending 57 minutes on
Facebook. A typical Twitter user was
spending about six minutes. You add that
as a second column, I'll wage you,
you'll start to explain even more why
there are difference in pricing across
companies. Think of this as a sequence.
When you first start as a userbased
company, people just look at the number
of users. At some point they're going to
say not all users are created equal. Are
you an active user? How active are you?
And at some point you're going to start
look at revenues per user, right?
Because ultimately you got to deliver
numbers. That transition happens. And as
that transition happens, you're going to
see the multiples being used will shift.
Today you look at online advertising
companies, users don't matter as much
anymore. It's driven by revenues because
a business has matured enough that
people say look I can look at the
revenues but you can see the logic for
why why investors do what they do
focusing on what they can see at the
time to explain differences.
So every example we've taken so far I've
taken a sector beverage sector the
banking sector the the trucking sector
picked a multiple try to explain
differences across that sector
right but with regressions you can
control for differences across
companies you're saying so what can I
compare a company to how the rest of the
market is being priced I don't see why
not you saying but there are differences
in cash flows growth and risk you're
absolutely right what What if I could
control for those differences using a
regression? The last segment of what I
want to talk about is how to price
companies against the entire
market. So at start of every year I take
every US stock. I compute the PE ratio
for every stock. I lose about twothirds
of my sample right there. Right? Because
you have negative earnings companies. I
take the companies with positive P
ratios and I try to explain difference
in PE ratios across those thousands of
companies. So now I'm looking at a
sample size of
thousands. The P ratio, do you remember
what the companion variable we said was
going to be? What know with price to
book is return and equity with EV to
sales it's margin with price
earnings? Earnings growth. So I said
okay earnings growth is your companion
variable. Let's see how good the linkage
is. And my stomach dropped when I did
the scatter plot between US stock PE
ratios and US growth. You see why my
stomach dropped? I'd have liked to see
this nice line with every, you know, all
the points bunched together. There's a
bit of a shotgun blast aspect to it,
right? If I squinted, maybe I can see a
positive slope, but this is not going to
be the strongest relationship. And
already I can see I shouldn't get my
hopes up when I run the regression about
what kind of R squared I'm going to get.
So, I'm I'm going to get a high R
square. And I run a regression of price
earnings against growth. Will I get a
high R squ or low R squared, do you
think? Now 9% and I'm going to add other
things that will help me. But when I add
payout and beta, I did I was actually
pleasantly surprised. I got a 24% R squ.
You're saying are you happy with it?
It's not a question of being happy or
unhappy. This is a mirror that shows you
how much uncertainty there is about PE
ratios. Hey, it wasn't my weapon of
choice. I wanted to do an discounted
cash flow valuation. You drag me into
pricing. You want to use PE ratios. I'm
going to show you how noisy they are
before you use them. Let's look at the
three variables and you tell me whether
the first let's start with the constant
16.09. This is start of 2025 US stocks.
What does the constant tell
me? Yes,
Sophia. It's a starting point, right?
It's like an average when everything
else is zero or the base. When markets
are highly priced, that base is going to
be higher. When start of 2025, US stocks
are highly priced. So, you're starting
with a high base. Let's move on to
growth rate.
51.916. How would I read that? Every 1%
increase in growth rates at US companies
increases the PE ratio by
0.52. What does that mean? If you're a
company with a growth rate 10% higher
than mine, your price earnings ratio
should be roughly 5.2. We're already
starting to quantify the effect of
growth. It does make sense. Higher
growth companies have higher PE ratios.
Every 1% increase in payout ratios
increases my PE ratio by 0.08. Not as
big an effect, but higher payout ratio
companies holding growth fixed will have
higher P ratios. That too makes sense.
And then you get to beta and it stops
making sense. Do you see
why? What do you see as a coefficient on
beta? as my beta
increases. No, no, wait. It should
increase or shouldn't?
Yeah.
In fact, when we did those intrinsic
value equations, when we increase,
you're saying what the heck is going on.
In a minute, I'm going to show you the
reason why it's happening, but the
reason is a statistical reason. So, I'm
going to take you back to your
statistics class and talk a little bit
about multiple regressions. I'm not a
statistics geek. So I I learned just
enough statistics to make myself
dangerous. And I'll stop there. There
are three things in this regression that
are kind of implicit. The first is the
kind of regression I've ran. It's a
linear regression. You know what that
means? As growth increases, you know,
price ratio increases
proportionately. There are fixes for
nonlinear relationship, but I'm assuming
a linear relationship. Second, since I'm
using this regression to estimate a PE
ratio for a company, I'm assuming
stationerity that the regression itself
is not changing between January and
April. And already you can see that's a
dangerous assumption because between
this year, between January and April,
think of how much has changed. That
constant has probably gone from 16.09 to
13.5. Who knows what the other
coefficients have done?
But there's a third assumption about
multiple regressions from statistics
that I think we talked about last
session which is if you run a multiple
regression that are independent
variables those independent variables
should be independent of each other.
They're supposed to be
uncorrelated. In fact in statistics
there's a word that statistics
professors use which
is close.
That's variance changing,
right? Multiolinearity is basically so
the you know we'll talk about that
because we're going to see very quickly
why this is going to be a problem in the
regression. So let's take those up.
First when you run a regression and you
look at these coefficients the first
thing you need to check is they're
statistically significant. In my
regression I think they all were right
these statistic 11 six seven. So they
all if they're not statistically
significant, what should you
do? Take them out of the regression.
They're going to create noise. You don't
want a noisy regression. So take them
out. Right?
Second, in some case when you run a
regression, the intercept can be
negative, right? In a picture, you can
see why it happens. The slope is is very
negative. It can cross the x-axis below
the zero. You're saying, so what?
Remember what you're using this
regression for to make predictions of
what the P ratio for individual
companies should be. If you have a big
negative intercept, you can end up with
negative PES for some companies on an
expected basis. And we can't handle
that, right? P ratios cannot be
negative. So you're saying what are we
going to do? In most statistics
packages, when you run a regression, it
gives you this option of do you want the
intercept to be zero? And if you say
yes, what it does is it tilts the line
to make it go through zero on the
x-axis. It's a less robust line because
you're not minimizing the square
distances, but it removes the negative
intercept. So when I run these
regressions with the market, if the
intercept is negative, I rerun the
regression without an intercept. That
way I don't have that negative intercept
throwing off my
predictions. But now let's talk about
the
multiolinearity. This is called a
correlation matrix.
standard tool tool in every statistics
toolkit. In fact, before you run
regressions, this is what you should
start with is running the correlation
matrix. If this were a perfect
regression, see the payout growth rate
in beta, every number off the diagonal
should be zero. In other words, there
should be no correlation between the
numbers. And that's not the case. High
growth companies tend to have high
betas. Are you surprised by that? I'm
not. High growth companies are riskier.
High growth companies tend to have lower
payout ratios. Again, no surprise.
Multiolinearity is almost baked into any
financial
regression. Can we fix it? Yeah, it'll
take us like 6 months of statistical
trick playing. But here's why I'm not
even going to bother. When you have
multiolinearity, the coefficients become
unstable. That's why the beta. So
essentially what's happening is when you
feed the computer four columns of data,
it doesn't know what the headings are.
It can't read the headings. It just sees
four columns of data. Let's assume all
your high growth companies have high
betas. You blame the computer for
getting confused at some point as to
what beta is measuring. Beta becomes a
standin for growth instead of risk. And
that's exactly why the coefficient on
beta is positive. The computer is
starting to think there are two
variables measuring growth. the growth
rate in the beta, the coefficients get
thrown off, but the regression still
holds. You can still use it as a as a
package, as a full regression to make
predictions for
companies. So that's basically all I'm
going to say about multiolinearity. But
don't be surprised when you run a
regression for your company against a
peer group to get a coefficient that is
the wrong sign. It's happening because
of multiolinearity.
Yeah, there are ways to do it.
Basically, you got to create new
variables which are orthogonal. It's a
pain in the neck. I'll be quite honest.
It's never really been productive time
for me. But if this were a statistics
class, this would be a great way to
refine regressions, learn how to deal
with multiolinearity because it's a fact
of life in finance. It's almost
everything you pick is going to be
correlated with something else about the
company.
Okay. Now the advant the reason you the
the this regression is a good starting
point is if you now came to me with a
company let's say Disney and you said is
Disney cheap or expensive I can try to
do an intrinsic valuation of Disney
right somebody in the class I'm sure
there are at least two or three people
doing Disney but that takes a lot of
work you got to tell revenue growth
stories and margins and reinvestment
let's take a shortcut what if I gave you
the growth rate for Disney the beta for
Disney and a payout ratio for it is
remember that regression from two pages
ago. I'm just going to plug in the
growth rate beta and payout into that
regression. I get a predicted P for
Disney of about
34. Given how the rest of the market is
being priced and given Disney's
fundamentals, it should trade at 34
times earnings. At the start of 2025,
Disney was trading at about 40 times
earnings. Let me pause right there.
Given the regression then what did I
conclude about Disney? Underpriced,
overpriced, cheap,
expensive. Yeah, overpriced because it's
trading at 40 times. And given how the
market is being priced, it should be
trading at 34 times earnings. It'll
become overpriced. If I do this for
every stock in the market, roughly half
of all stocks are going to be
underpriced and half are going to be
overpriced. That's an H with a
regression. Many of them are going to
fall within that 90% confidence
interval. Why? Because most regressions
most of the day. But there will be
companies on either end, right?
Underpriced, very underpriced, very
overpriced enough to be no off that 90.
So if you running a hedge fund, what
would you do? You'd buy the really
underpriced. You'd sell the really
overpriced and then hope and pray that
they move to the regression line.
We make quant investing sound like this
amazing comp. Quantum investing is
basically this regression on a much more
sophisticated statistical level. So
think of having this data. This is very
simplistic, right? We run a simp
multiple linear regression. You can make
the regression nonlinear. You can bring
a non quantitative data in. you can try
to get better because ultimately that
becomes the endgame is to find out what
a fair pricing is and use it to judge
which stocks are underpriced and which
are
overpriced. Any questions on running a
regression across the market? I'm not
going to ask you to do the regression,
but I will give you the marketwide
regressions. And if any of you at some
point in time become curious enough
about data, this is a great data set to
master statistics on with a payoff of if
you actually get something going, you
can make money on it, right? So that's
basically what we're trying to do. One
final thing about the PE regression. If
you remember the coefficient on growth
rate was 0.52. What does that mean? The
market is paying 0.52 in PE for every 1%
growth rate. So think of that as the
price of growth. So that's the red
column 0.52. You know what the black
line is? That's the equity risk premium.
You think why do we have both in the
same graph? The equity risk premium is
the price of risk in the market. The
coefficient on growth is the price of
growth in the
market. Go back to 2000. 2000 look at
the price that the market was willing to
pay for growth. And look at the price of
risk. Risk was priced really low. growth
was priced really high. This is like
nirvana for a high growth, high-risisk
company, right? You're going to trade at
250 times earnings because I'm paying a
huge premium for growth and charging
very little for risk. Of course, that
shifted very quickly when the dot boom
bust. So every year I keep track of this
growth coefficient and I put in this
graph because I want to get a sense of
am I looking like 2000 or am I looking
at like a more normal time period
because that's going to give me a sense
of mispricing across the entire
market. I'll do one more multiple before
we kind of put the pricing to rest. We
talked about PEG ratios. I told you I
don't like them because they have the
strange properties behave very
differently with growth than any other
multiple. I wanted to do a regression of
peg ratios and the first thing I tried
was peg against the growth
rate. Does it look even remotely linear
to
you? Like if it's linear, it's going to
be straight line right down the end,
right? Okay. And if you bring in the
data, it looks like if there's a curve,
remember I said I talked about that
bludgeon of doing the natural log. This
is what the scatter plot looks like with
the natural
log. A little better, right? At least I
can fit a line through it. It's it's a
it's a shortcut blast. The R squ is not
going to be high, but I have a chance of
a linear regression now. So when I run
the PEG ratio regression, first look at
the the R squares. It's getting even
worse than the PE ratio. But now we look
at the coefficients. They're all
statistically significant. Higher growth
companies on average have lower PEG
ratios, which makes sense, right? The
denominator goes up. Higher risk
companies have higher PEG ratios. We
still have that multiolinearity problem.
And higher payout ratio companies do
have higher PEG ratios.
Start of every year I run these
regressions for PE ratios, PEG ratios,
price to book ratios, EV to EBIDA, EV to
invested capital and EV to cell six
multiples. I run them by
region, US, Europe, Japan, Australia,
New Zealand, emerging markets
collectively. And I run a global
regression. Once you valued, you've
already finished your valuation with
your DCF. Some of you might be getting
close close to pricing your company
against the sector. There's one final
piece of the project you're taking a
look at that you have to complete which
is you have to price your company
against the entire
market. Since I don't want you running
this regression, you just don't have the
time to do it. You're welcome to use my
regression from the start of the year.
Plug in your company's numbers and
you're saying which one should I use? If
you're, you know, if you're a US
company, you might say, "I want to use
the US regression. If you're a
multinational, you might use a global
regression. If you're an emerging
market, pick your market regression.
Plug your company's numbers in, see what
you get as a predicted multiple." And
over the next six pages, you'd see this
for P ratios, PEG. So each multiple,
you'd see this broken down. So you can
see PEG, price to book. Now, obviously,
I'm not no each of these regression
though, I'm using the same variables for
every region. Okay. So you see price to
book is beta return equity payout and
these are not randomly picked. They're
the variables that showed up when I did
that intrinsic value section. Yep.
Because Japan for a long time was very
different from the rest of Asia. Now I
should probably bundle it in with the
rest of Asia because until 15 years ago
Japan was the only developed market in
Asia. The rest of Asia was emerging
markets. Right now they're converging.
You could probably throw in China and
India and with Japan, but that just
reflects a history since I have this
history archive data going back 30
years. I've stuck with the original
classifications. I do India and China
separately now because those markets are
big enough. But essentially, you can do
it in any market. You can take the
Turkish market. You can take any market
and run these market regressions to see
how companies are within that market.
So I think uh you you can so depending
on the multiple you pick you can go to
the page which has the multiple pick the
region plug your numbers in no but
effectively I'm taking the same process
and repeating in every part
of so let's let's review the pricing
process. First thing you're going to do
when you price your companies you have
to decide whether you want to use market
cap enterprise value or firm value. the
numerator, the starting point. What's
that going to be driven by? If you have
a financial service company, there's no
choice to make. Always use an equity
value. But banks, insurance companies,
investment banks. For other companies,
the choice will depend on how much
difference there is in leverage across
companies. If you're uncertain, use an
enterprise value multiple. It's always
safer. But if there's not much
difference in leverage across companies,
you can get away using an equity
multiple. Second stop, you have to pick
a scalar. You know what I mean by
scalar? What goes in the denominator? It
can be revenues, it can be earnings, it
can be number of users if you feel
that's what works. Book
value, cash
flow. Third stop, you have to decide the
timing of that scalar with earnings. The
earnings can be the most recent fiscal
year. It can be trailing 12 months. It
can be forward earnings. It can even be
normalized earnings. Remember, whatever
you do for one company, you got to do
for all of the companies. So if you want
to normalize earnings, normalize them
for all other companies in your group.
Which one you pick will depend in in
great part of sector you're looking at.
If you're looking at commodity
companies, you might decide to normalize
things because the earnings are
volatile. And finally, I'm going to ask
you what's going to be in your
comparables. And remember the choice I I
gave you. Do you want to go narrow and
pick companies just like yours or
broader? That choice is going to be
determined by how you control for
differences across companies and whether
there are differences across different
parts of the world in that particular
business. Banks for instance I tend to
stay focused regionally because
regulatory rules vary across regions. So
I don't want to compare cityroup to
state bank of India because I might be
comparing apples and oranges. So there
is no one path. So if you ask me what is
the right multiple for my company? My
answer is there is no right multiple.
Pick the one that works the best. How
will you know what that is? First, are
you losing a lot of companies when you
pick this multiple? So, you pick a
multiple and two/3s of your sample drops
off. Not a good
multiple. Second, can you explain
differences in multiples well with that
multiple? So, if you're under
regressions, one multiple you can
explain 70% of what's going on. And now
that you can explain only 15%, go with
the 70%.
It'll give you a much more robust
pricing and one that you can base your
recommendations
on. So, let's let's close up pricing
with some general proposition, none of
which should be surprising.
First, when you price your company,
you're making a statement that's very
specific that this company is cheap or
expensive given the other companies
you're comparing it to. Right? Second,
in pricing, there's no such thing as a
company that looks just like yours. No
matter how hard you try, your peer group
will have differences from your company
on growth and risk and payout. You can
act like they're not there, which is
what lots of analysts do, or you can
bring them in and use statistical tools
to control for differences. I would
strongly encourage you, even if you
haven't run a regression in months and
years, to try that process out with your
peer group to see if you can control for
differences. Pricing is not rocket
science. It's just pure data analysis
and you basically go with wherever the
data takes you, right? There's no right
number or wrong number. This is what the
market is paying for these
companies. Define, describe, analyze,
apply. Okay, remember the definitional
test. Is it consistently defined? Is it
uniformly estimated? Description just
pure money ball. Put up the histogram.
See how asymmetric the average, the
median, the
mean. Analyze with an equity multiple,
go back to a dividend discount model.
With an enterprise value multiple, go
back to an enterprise valuation model.
And only then apply the multiple. Do
pricing. Well, I have no problem with
pricing. And that might be mo most of
you if you end up in jobs in equity
research or in banking. Your job is a
pricing job. It's good to be good at
pricing even if it's not your first
instinct. So learn the process. Don't
get too caught up in I'm an intrinsic
value person. I will never price
companies. And guess what? Your job
might require you to price companies.
Might as well do it
right. Talk about assetbased valuation.
So let's set the table. Most times when
you value companies, you value the
entire company. Let's call that
aggregated
valuation. But you can also value a
company in pieces. What does that mean?
If it's a multi-reional company, you can
value every geography. If you're a
multi- business company, you can value
each business separately. And if you're
a user based company, you can even value
individual users. If you remember in the
very first class I talked about Netflix
user and how much that user is worth and
why the value of a Netflix user in the
US can be five times higher than the
value of a Netflix user in
India. So when we talk about some of the
parts it doesn't always have to be in
breakdown. You look puzzled. Why is a
Netflix user in the US five times more
valuable than a Netflix user in
India? How does Netflix make money?
Who has a net? Does anybody have a
Netflix India subscription? You have a
Netflix. How much do you pay per
month? 200 rupees which works out to
$25. How much do you pay for your
Netflix? Too much. So that's exactly it,
right? $25 a month. You have a lot more
Indian. So you say lot more but per
subscriber and Indian subscribers will.
And so you could actually go around the
region. Netflix European subscriber,
Netflix US subscriber, Netflix Indian
subscriber, value them, add them all up.
That's what a sum of the parts valuation
will give you. You're saying, why would
I ever want to value a company as a sum
of its parts? And that was your your
starting point. There are three places
you do. One is when you do liquidation
valuation. Why? Because you're selling
the pieces off. Think of yourself as
running a huge eBay site where you're
selling the pieces of a company
individually. You got to value it in
pieces. The second is in fair value
accounting. Why? Because in fair value
accounting, your job is to take each
line item on a balance sheet, put a
number on it. And the third is when you
want to value a company as the sum of
its parts because you want to break it
up or you want to make money because you
think it's being mispriced relative to
the sum of the
parts. So with any company, you can try
to value it as a sum of its part. So the
val or asset based valuation. But let's
set the table as to what kinds of
companies asset based valuation is going
to be easiest to do.
Okay? When I talked about different ways
of valuing
companies, notice I didn't have
assetbased valuation as a different
approach. I did intrinsic value,
pricing, and
options. You know why I didn't create
assetbased valuation as a as a carveout?
Because to value an individual
asset, you got to you got to choose,
right? Are you going to do an intrinsic
valuation? You can value each asset
based on its cash flows, growth, and
risk. Are you going to price the asset?
Or worst of all, are you going to trust
the accountants when they tell you how
much an asset is worth, which is what we
do when we trust book value, right?
We're trusting the accountant sum of the
parts. So, let's think about when it is
easiest to value a company as the sum of
its
parts. It's easier to value a company as
a sum of its parts if the assets it has
are separable. I'll give you a classic
example. Let's say you have a company
that owns 10 real estate properties,
each of which it collects rental income
from. You see why valuing it as a sum of
its parts is going to be easy. Each
building is standalone. Each building
has its own earnings. I can value each
piece separately and there's almost no
cross synergies to worry
about. Conversely, if I'm trying to
value Disney, valuing it as a sum of its
parts is going to be really, really
difficult to do. Why? Because the
earnings and revenues of the theme park
business is going to be driven by how
well the movie business is doing and how
well the movie business is doing can
affect the value of the streaming
business. It's going to be much more
difficult to do because the businesses
are not separable. It'll be nice if with
each of these businesses there's an
active market of companies that are only
in that
business. Right? So real estate again
it's easy because real estate is traded.
I can take take each property attach a
pricing or evaluation to that property.
So that's when valuing as the sum of the
assets or the sum of the pieces is going
to be easiest to
do. So with that lead and let's talk
about the three places you might have to
do assetbased
valuation. First is liquidation
valuation. How do I come up with
liquidation value? I can take the lazy
way out and take book value, right? But
there I'm assuming that what the
accountant is giving me as numbers for
the assets is what I can get in a
liquidation. And you can see why that's
going to get you into
trouble. The second is you can do an
intrinsic valuation of each asset. But
let's face it, in liquidation, who's
going to pay you intrinsic value? You
probably should be pricing these assets
because that's what you're trying to do.
You're trying to sell the assets today.
And if you're in a
hurry, might you have to take a
discount? Absolutely. So liquidation
valuation is really pricing. It's
pricing individual assets, accepting a
discount based on how quickly you think
that's going to be easy to do. Who's
doing weightatches? Somebody is doing
Weight Watchers. I know this glass,
right? Nobody seems to admit to the
company they're doing. I know you're
doing it because I saw your DCF.
Weight Watchers is on the verge of
bankruptcy. Can you imagine being the
person given the task of estimating the
liquidation value of Weight
Watchers? What are the assets you're
going to be selling? The name
maybe probably not a good name to have
anymore. Weight Watchers sounds like
you're being judgmental.
You've got a list of people who are
Weight Watcher because it used to have a
fairly loyal group of people who maybe
you can sell the list but beyond that
you're going to be scrabbling for what
other assets do I have as a company.
Maybe they have a headquarters building.
I don't even know. Liquidation value is
easy in the abstract but actually coming
up with the number when you're in a
hurry to to cash out can give you a
fraction of what you see on the balance
sheet. That's the first stop.
Second is accountingbased fair
value. About 20 years ago, the GAP the
committee at the GAP that was writing
the fair value accounting rules met in
New York. And I got a call from somebody
in the committee saying, "Would you be
willing to come and talk to the
committee because we're interested in
doing this fair value accounting?" And I
said, "Are you sure you've got the right
guy? You know what I think about
accountants, right?" They said, "No, no,
we know exactly what you think about
accountants, but we'd like to talk to
you about value." And I said, "Okay, can
you send me what you're thinking about
as fair value accounting?" And they sent
me this fast 157, which is the rule that
governs fair value accounting in GAP. If
you get a chance, read FAS 157 because I
did. And here's what I saw. Faz 157
requires accountants to put a number on
an asset based on what you can get for
that asset in an armslength transaction
from a market participant. Let me repeat
that again. In a fair value accounting,
you're required to put a number in an
asset based on what you can get in an
arms length transaction from a market
participant. As I read that to step back
and say, is this a value mission or a
pricing mission? When you read that,
what is it? What what do you get out of
it? Am I being asked to price things or
value them? It's a pricing thing. So I
wrote back and before I even came to the
committee, I said, "Are you sure you got
the right name for what you're doing?
This should be fair price accounting,
not fair value accounting." They had no
idea what I was talking about, which
told me we're in
trouble. But here's the problem with
fair value accounting. The mission is a
pricing mission. But what are
accountants required to do to back up
that number? do a full-fledged
discounted cash flow valuation. This is
a recipe for frustration because you're
trying to come up with a number for
something based on a pricing and then
reverse engineering a DCF model to
deliver the same value. Fair value
accounting is pricing and the sooner we
accept that the less frustration there
will be in the process and the better
the pricing process. No, fair value
accounting should never be using a DCF
model. It should be based on multiples
and comparables and basically coming up
with the pricing that makes
sense. Which brings me to the third
setting in which you might do asset
based
valuation. You might want to value a
company as the sum of its parts. Why? As
a passive investor, what are you hoping
will happen if the value of the sum of
the parts is greater than the price
today? That the market will correct and
move up. If you're an activist investor,
Sophia, what would you do if the sum of
the parts is greater than the value of
the company
today? First, you are to buy you have to
buy the company first and then you sell
off the pieces, get the value. And at
different points in time, companies like
Sony and Disney have been targeted for
the sum of the parts
valuation. Activist has said you should
break the company up. So I want to talk
a little bit about valuing or pricing a
company for a sum of the parts analysis.
So I'm going to take a company where I
had the information to be able to do
this reasonably well. No you've heard of
a company called United
Technologies. It's a it's a
conglomerate. In fact some of the names
I'm going to list as divisions I'm sure
you've heard of. It's in six different
business very different businesses.
First is a business called Kerry which
makes refrigeration systems. The second
is Prattton Whitney which is a defense
company. Otus which makes elevators. So
it's a it's a building construction
company. UTC Fire and Security which is
a security company but as its name
indicates Hamilton Sunstrren which is a
manufacturing company and Sikorski which
makes those helicopters. It's an
aircraft company. And the nice thing
about United Technologies is not only
they break themselves down into these
six businesses, they gave me not just
revenues by business, they gave me EIDA,
operating income, capex, depreciation,
and total
assets. Very few companies give you that
level of detail. So, as I go through
United Technologies, you're going to see
me able to do stuff that I might not be
able to do at a Disney, for instance.
So, first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to do what's called a naive
pricing, which is what most equity
research analysts do when they do a sum
of the parts valuation. What's a
pricing? See this EIDA number that I
have by business? If I told you what
multiple of EIDA companies in each of
these businesses trade at, I could apply
that multiple to the ABIDA and come up
with an estimated
pricing. Why is this naive? What what am
I implicitly assuming here when I take
the median EV to EIDA of companies in
each of these businesses and apply it to
the EIDA
company not just the cap structure the
operating details the margins the
revenue growth pretty much every part of
my story has to be the same right and if
I buy into that the pricing I get for
the six parts is 61.7 billion the next
time you see an equity research analyst
Let's talk about some of the parts
valuation. This is what he or she has
done. In which case, it should be a sum
of the pots valuation. It be a pricing
and not even a good pricing. It's a very
it's a back of the envelope pricing.
Something you would do after three
drinks or after a long dinner and you
say, "I'm drunk, but I'm going to price
the company anyway. Let me take an
envelope, write it on the back, multiply
six numbers, and come up with an
estimate." Could we do pricing better
here, though?
How do we when we talked about doing
pricing better? What did we do? We ran
regressions and we try to control for
differences, right? So, I'm going to try
to do a slightly more. So, let's call
this sophisticated pricing as opposed to
naive pricing. First thing in
sophisticated pricing, I can actually
have different multiples for different
businesses. How do I pick the multiples?
I tried different multiples in each
sector and pick the multiple that are
the highest R squared. So I've got three
different variants here. EV to capital,
EV to revenue, EV to EIA. And you're
seeing me kind of mix and
match. And within each pure group, I ran
a regression against growth and the the
companion variables. I plugged in the
values for United Technologies into
those regressions and what I get as a
predicted number. So basically those are
the regressions with United Technology
numbers. Those are my those are my
estimated pricing with the regression
that controls for differences between
United Techno and the rest of the peer
group. My pricing is 74.2 billion. What
is the naive pricing? Do you remember? I
think it was 61 billion. So if you see
those differences, what does it tell you
about United Technology as a company?
Run more efficiently than the rest of
the peer groups. Run less
efficiently. I'm attaching a higher
pricing after I control for differences.
It's run more efficiently. It's more
profitable. Higher growth. It's doing
something that the pure group was unable
to do. Still a pricing, but a pricing
that controls for differences. So, I've
got two numbers now for United
Technologies. A naive pricing 61
billion, a kind of sophisticated pricing
74 billion. Can I do an intrinsic
valuation of each of the six
businesses? I don't say why not, right?
To do that, I need revenue, growth, cash
flow. So in other words, think about
running each of the businesses
separately as a discounted cash flow
valuation. I need a cost of capital by
business,
right? Given the way we approach
estimating betas, which is looking at
bottom up betas, I can estimate a beta
and a cost of cap for each of the six
businesses and they vary right you look
at Hamilton fire and security 6.78% at
the other extreme I think it's Otus and
Sakorski have cost of capital close to
10%.
riskier and safer business is each one
gets its own cost of
capital. So I've got a cost of cap for
each business. If I can somehow flesh
out the cash flows and growth rates for
each business, I'm almost there. I'm
going to take a shortcut. Remember when
margins are stable, you can estimate
growth by multiplying the return on
capital by the reinvestment rate. Most
of the time we don't use it because
assuming margins are but here I don't
have the time or the energy or the
resources to do it individually. So what
I did was I estimated a return on
capital and reinvestment rate for each
of the six businesses. And you can see
that fire and security in addition to
being the safest business has the worst
return on capital. So big difference in
return capital, big difference in
reinvestment rates. I'm going to use the
product of those two as my expected
growth rate when I do the discounted
cash flow
valuation. So here's the last step.
Basically I have for each of the
businesses I I have different discounted
cash flow models. In fact for UTC fire
and security I used a mature stable
growth model already. For my remaining
five businesses I allowed for five years
of growth where the growth rates vary
widely across the businesses. See that's
the advantage of some of the parts
valuation is each part can be given its
own
characteristics. I do an intrinsic
valuation of each part. I add the
intrinsic valuations up based on my
intrinsic
valuation. The sum of the intrinsic
values for the company is 80.25
billion. I'm almost done. I have a third
estimate of value. But there's one catch
in my intrinsic valuation that I have to
bring in. This company had $48 million
in expenses that were unallocated across
the business. It was given as a separate
line
item. Can I just assume it
away? What's that general expense? It's
some shared expense, right,
Sophia? Exactly. But so it's something
that these six businesses sharing that
somebody at the headquarters is doing,
right? So here's my final step. I took
the $48 million. It's a cost. Assumed it
will continue in perpetuity. Somebody
it's cost is to go somewhere. Took the
present value of the cost. It's 5 4.6
billion. And I'm going to subtract that
from my intrinsic value of the sum. Do
you see why I have to subtract? It's
expenses that have gone nowhere that I'm
taking on. I have three valuation three
numbers for the company. 75.7 billion
from the intrinsic valuation. some of
the
parts 74 billion from the sophisticated
pricing and and 71 and when I did the
value of the company as a as an
aggregated company I got about 71
billion as well so if I take just those
two numbers 71 billion versus 75 billion
you're saying where's the extra 4
billion coming from it's coming from
finessing different parts of the
business and giving them different
characteristics that's what we lose when
we value companies as aggregated holds
we lose that differences across
businesses that might lead some business
to be worth more than others. Questions
of
you wanted to ask if you're an activist,
right? But if you're a passive investor,
clearly that's off the table. So why
might you still value a company as the
sum of its parts even though you're a
passive
investor? How do we make money? We make
money when the price adjusts to the
value. Right? So what you're hoping for
is a catalyst. When you have a company
that has multiple parts with different
values, all you need as a catalyst is
one of those parts being devested or
sold off. And you as a passive investor
even though you're not the one doing it
benefit because at that time people
revisit the company. So I agree with you
as a passive investor you don't control
the outcome as much but you might still
do some of the part saying I will
benefit because somebody out there is
going to notice this and come and buy
one of the parts from the company and
I'm going to be the beneficiary when
that happens.
You know the benefits or not just what
synergies have we counted in though we
haven't counted any
negotiates for steel or enterprises
together as a consumer
that's a good point in fact you could
ask maybe some of these benefits will
disappear when they're sold off as
pieces in which case when we do the sum
of the parts we shouldn't be using the
stated EIDA we should be using an
adjusted version but given that that's
going to be tough to get which may might
make the naive pricing your best
estimate, right? Because if you move
towards the average when that happens,
you're going to end up with the naive
pricing, right? Yes.
What do you do if you don't have that?
I cheated. What did I use as my debt
ratio for every I use the market debt to
cap that I hope for the whole company as
a debt to cap for every division.
I'll tell you when I would not do it. If
I did Disney, for instance, I know the
theme park business carries more debt
than the broadcasting business there. I
might try to finesse it, but most of the
time if you have multiple businesses and
they don't borrow on their own, better
just let it ride and kind of attach the
same debt ratio to every company.
So stock was actually the market cap for
the company was actually 52 billion at
the time that I did
this. I ended up United Technologies in
my portfolio for a while based on the
sum of the parts valuation and as Sophia
said you're making a bet on a catalyst
showing up recently. I think there they
sold off Sikorski finally but that's how
the catalyst kick in is a piece gets
know somebody looks at and say that's a
great business I'm going to buy it pays
a high price then people reassess the
company and you benefit from it
right I hate the colors I picked for it
I'm sorry this is evaluation I did of GE
in 2018 by 2018 G was a fallen giant new
CEO had come in and his job was very
simple it to unravel the company, sell
off the
pieces. It took him almost five years to
do it. And to see why, here's what I
did. I took the one to eight businesses
GE was in, and I valued each business
separately. In this section, I actually
took each part, came up with the cost of
capital. You can see the cost of capital
vary widely based on the business you're
in. I did an intrinsic valuation of each
business and I came up with a total
value of 204 billion for all of the
businesses put
together. They should be able to split
it up. And there's one part of GE that
made it almost impossible to break up GE
and that was GE Capital. G Capital in
2018 had an estimated value of 27
billion. Not bad, right? But look at how
much debt it carried. 84 billion. By
itself, GE Capital was draining almost
47 billion or is it 57 billion? 57
billion in value from the company. You
have business that's draining 57 billion
in value. What should you do? Just shut
it down. Right? So, why didn't G shut
down GE Capital? What was the problem
that they faced with GE Capital?
Almost every other business was
entangled with GE Capital. G Aviation.
What do they do? They sell aircraft
engines to companies financed by guess
who? G Capital. G Capital became this
toxic mess that delayed the G now is
broken up. It's been sold off. But it
took almost a decade to do it because
getting GE Capital out of the company
became so difficult to do. And I know J
Jack Welch for a brief time was viewed
as this incredible CEO, you know.
But Jack, this was Jack Welch's
creation. He brought GE Capital into GE,
made G the largest market cap company in
the world, got lauded as one of the
greatest CEOs of all time. But he also
created the beginning of a mess that
effectively ended up costing GE billions
of dollars and 10 years of trying to get
out of the business. It's one reason
when when companies start capital
businesses they have to be wary because
if that business stops working it's very
difficult to shut it down sell it off or
unravel
it. I also did a pricing of G and you
get the same kind of phenomena because
some of the pricing was about 212
billion G capital was still the drain on
value.
Yes, it was. It allowed GE to become a
$500 billion company. GE became the
largest market cap company in the world.
GE Capital was a big part of it becoming
at one point in time GE Capital was the
largest financial service company in the
US, bigger than any bank, right? So, it
allowed GE to power itself to the top.
But on its way down, it also became this
albatross around their neck because it
was so difficult to so it stopped being
a good business. Normally, if you have a
bad business, you shut it down. But with
the capital business, shutting it down
becomes almost a non-starter because
it's entangled in all of your other
businesses. So, it's a bet that paid off
for a while, but eventually it turns
sour, right? So, I'm going to at least
get started on private company
evaluation because next session we're
going to
Do is anybody valuing a private
business? I think Lisa is. So, here we
go. I'm going to start by talking about
what makes private business valuation a
little messier than public
companies. The basic process stays the
same. What's the value of business? The
present value, the expected cash flows
discounted back at a risk adjusted
discount rate. That doesn't change
private businesses. And as with
traditional businesses, you can value
just the equity, you can value the whole
business. There are two things you will
lack in a private business that you
might find yourself missing. The first
is there's no market price. You think so
what? We're going to talk about the
different places where we go for market
prices in a traditional valuation and
how missing it can become a problem. The
second is that the financial statements
for private businesses might not be in
the same format as for public companies.
So you might think you understand gap
but then I give you a private business
and the numbers might look very
different. So let's start with the
absence of a market
price and let's see how it plays
out. There are places in discounted cash
flow valuation where we need the market
price as an input. Take a classic
example. How do we compute the cost of
capital for a publicly traded
company? We take the market value of
equity and debt. We wait based on market
values. There's no market value for a
private business. So the question is how
do we come up with the weights for the
cost of capital? We're going to talk
about that. It's not going to be as
straightforward as computing the cost of
capital of a public
company. And once you're done with your
value, and be honest with me, when you
got a value per share, what's the first
number you
checked? Actual price. Why? Because if
you got $2 a share and the market price
is $2,000 a share, you know you screwed
up somewhere, right? Markets don't make
that kind of mistake. We use the market
price to kind of finesse our way because
if the numbers too different, we know we
screwed up. It's nice to have the market
price as output to compare it
to. And finally, we didn't do this, but
if your betas come from regressions, you
need market prices to get regressions,
right?
You don't know what you're missing until
you actually miss it. So when you value
private business, you realize how much
you depend on the market price as a
crutch all the way through valuation.
The first one, second, when you look at
the income statements, the cash flow of
private company, there are four issues
that you will run into that you got to
factor in. The first is much of the time
you'll have fewer years of history for a
private company than for most public
companies. Not always, but
Second, those accounting standards,
especially when you get to small private
businesses, can diverge a lot more than
accounting standards across public
companies. I still remember in one of
these slides about 10 years ago, student
in the class decides to value a mother's
flower
shop. It's doing well. She said, "Can I
value my mother's flower shop?" I said,
"By all means." 6 weeks in, she comes in
and she says, "I have to change
companies." I said, "What happened? Do
you fight with your mom or something?"
She said, "I went and asked my mom for
her financials, and she took me into
this back room where every wall was
covered with post-it notes." I said,
"Mom, what is this?" She said, "That
wall is my revenue wall. That wall is my
expense wall." So, what she did was she
wrote post-it notes and post put them on
the wall. She had a business to run. At
the end of the year, I guess she pulled
down all the post-it notes, create an
income statement. I don't think posted
accounting is allowed under the GAP or
IFRS. If you're a small business, it can
happen. The third problem is in many
private businesses, the line between the
personal and the business is kind of a
gray one, right? There's a company car,
but every afternoon at 3:00 just as
school lets out, the car seems to
disappear. It always comes
back. But there is that line. Now what
is and finally and this is something
when you value private business you got
to factor in and Lisa could tell me
whether she did is if you have an owner
of a private business they generally
don't pay themselves a salary. Why?
Because they get whatever's left over
anyway. You see why this matters? If you
look at the income statement for a
private business that income is going to
be overstated because I'm not factoring
in the time of the owner and what it
would cost me to replace that owner. You
watch Shark T. This is actually one of
those parts of Shark Tank that are
mindboggling. These four people get on
and they say, "Last year we made
$100,000 in
profits." And one of the sharks always
asks the question, right? What's the
question? Did you pay yourself a salary?
Not really. So basically
each value at time at $25,000 a year
because if you factor in the salary,
you're not making money. It looks like
you're making money, but we have to
somehow talk about what does the owner
do? How much does that will it cost to
replace the owner if I have to come up
with an income for the
business? So, I leave you with one final
part of private company valuation that
is always a struggle. About 20 years
ago, I'm sitting in my office. This lady
barges into my office almost like she
owned the office. She walks in and she
says,"I heard you teach valuation." I
said, 'I teach corporate strategy. I was
trying to escape her, but she said, 'I
know you teach valuation. I said, '
Okay, you got me. What do you want? She
said, I want a value for my business.
It's a candy company. I said, why? She
said, what do you mean why? I said, are
you
curious? Are you having a divorce? Maybe
you want know your soon to be ex- spouse
gets half the business. Maybe you've got
a fight with the tax guy and you want a
number for your business or maybe you're
trying to sell the business. She thought
about it for a moment. She said, "Will
it matter?" I said, "Yes, if you're
having a divorce, you probably want to
see zero as the value of your business
and you want that
value." Private company valuation motive
matters because unless you tell me why
you want the number, I can't give you a
blanket number of say this is the value.
So, she said it's for a transaction. And
I said to whom? She said, 'You have a
lot of questions. I said, 'I need to
know.' She said, 'What do you mean to
whom? Is it to an individual? Is it to a
private equity investor? Is it to a
company? Next session when we start,
we're going to see why that matters.
Because the way you attach a value to a
private business is going to be a
function of why you're doing the
valuation and who you're doing the
valuation for. Something we never had to
wrestle with in public company
valuation. So next class we'll talk
about private company evaluation and
maybe introduce a couple of ideas on how
to do it better.